une question avant de vous présenter
quelqu'un qui raconte des histoires
extraordinaires est ce que vous imitez
quelques toiles et cris d'animaux
et du coq noblesse oblige
c'est à la portée de tout le monde je
vous présente jacques très moche qui est
le personnage qui tous les mercredis
nous raconte des histoires
extraordinaires et j'en suis sûre qui
aujourd'hui va nous raconter une
histoire bah j'avais préparé autre chose
mais après à non mais alors jacques on
ne peut parler ya maintenant qu des
oisons imitateur fini oui les oiseaux
imitateur mais connaissait tous le père
auquel mais inat mais y en a beaucoup
d'autres d'ailleurs qu'on connaît mal et
qui imite sans qu'on leur demande le jet
dans la forêt imite le cri du hibou le
corbeau une mite le grincement de la
charrette quand ils ont avoué qu'ils
intéressent ils commencent à limiter
beaucoup de passereaux imitent leurs
champs les uns des geôles pourquoi les
savons vous ont dit récemment qu'il
imitait par esprit d'imitation voit bien
ça veut dire quoi qu'ils imitent pour
s'amuser tout bêtement bien voilà le
vrai problème c'est les oiseaux qui
parle comme nous perreault kelme et inat
par exemple est ce qu'ils savent ce
qu'ils disent alors là il ya eu une
grosse discussion pendant des siècles
messieurs les savants ont dit ray ça me
manque c'est pas possible le cerveau du
perroquet le cerveau du mail nath est
trop petit il n'est pas fait pour penser
non il peu pareil peut pas
d'autre but que je vais les apparences
devrait il ya certains par exemple le
mainate de line renaud quand il commence
ma cabane au canada il sait pas ce que
c'est qu'une cabane au canada c'est bien
évident de même que le may not qui a
gagné la dernière guerre il sait pas ce
que c'est c'était cette année la très
célèbre d'ailleurs il s'appelait rafle
un mainate américain tout ce qu'ils
savaient on n'était pas plus malin que
les autres mais il savait chanter
l'hymne américain bon et puis là dessus
on vers la lol l'amérique entre en
guerre et la besoin d'argent elle
organise des réunions publiques des
meetings et puis des émissions à la
radio et à la télé pour collecter des
fonds pour son effort de guerre lors y
avait des gens qui venaient d'y
prononcer un grand discours patriotique
et puis à la fin et design maintenant
tous ensemble et le mainate entonnaient
l'hymne américain tout le monde
applaudissait on payait et les gens
souscrivent est des bons du trésor qui
ont permis paraît-il à l'amérique de
tout de même faire un effort d'armement
est bien évident que ce pays n'a tu ne
savais pas ce qu'il chantait puis à
dessus après la guerre les savons les
zoologues s'était mis à étudier
les moyens de communiquer les résumant
leur façon de vivre leur langage il
avait découvert des choses
extraordinaires qu'on a fini par se
demander si tout de même le perroquet
par exemple quand il parle c'est pas un
petit peu ce qu'il dit et tout a
commencé parce qu'un soldat américain
avait été un perroquet un chien et un
jardin et 13 ans attend le chien elle
est dans le jardin alors le patron le
maître disait dick revenez je vous pris
10 cents américains et le perroquet
écouter ça et puis au bout de cinq six
dix fois un jour où le patron n'était
pas là le chien va dans un jardin et le
perroquet diddy promener je vous prie le
chien est rentré tout piteux à partir de
ce moment là le perroquet enchanté
d'avoir fait une blague au chien du
helmand toutes les voix que malheureux
chien quitter la pièce dirait des creux
venez je vous prie là dessus le son
patron qui était au look ciref réfléchi
et se dit mais bon il s'est peut-être
pas ce que veut dire venez s'il vous
plaît mais tout de même c'est qu'il faut
le dire là dessus on a fait beaucoup
d'expérience et on a fini par découvrir
que le perroquet quand il parle ne sais
pas ce qu'il dit mais il sait qu'il faut
le dire je voulais je vais parler comme
un savon il sait ce qu'il faut dire dans
telle ou telle circonstance j'ai pas
exactement ce que ça veut dire mais il
sait que dans tel cas il faut dire que
quelqu'un arrive faut lui dire bonjour
j'ai connu un perroquet qui quand on le
titille vous dirai je vous remercie de
votre visite votre conversation m'a
beaucoup intéressé évidemment il savait
parce que je l'avais dit ce perroquet
mais il savait qu'à ce moment là ça
faisait de l'effet compte utiliser ça et
tout bien considéré le perroquet qui ne
sait pas ce qu'il dit mais qui sait
qu'il faut le dire au moment où il le
dit il a le niveau intellectuel d'un
enfant de deux ans et la relaxe qui
résout enfin le problème le perroquet à
le quotient intellectuel comme nous
disons d'un gosse de deux ans et au
surpluss un peu de chacun de nous nous
avons tous ce matin dit bonjour à un tas
de gens bonjour ça veut dire j'espère
que vous passerez une bonne journée est
ce que une seule fois en disant bonjour
bonjour bonjour vous avez pensé que vous
espériez que le monsieur à qui vous
disaient bonjour passera une bonne
journée bien sûr que l'eau nous avons
parlé comme des perroquets savions pas
ce que nous disions une savions qu'il
fallait le dire à ce moment là